good morning believe nation today's
message is seize the opportunity over
the use Latin Ibrahimovic before 17 I
was like the last one to they consider
to become good I mean one day the first
coach of the first team he went out and
he saw me in a game and he was like I
wanna have a meeting with you and I was
like okay what did i do no I mean every
time I had a meeting was for some kind
of disciplinary thing and and then he
said on Monday I start to train with the
big guys you are in a first team and
then I was like from considering to be
the not the biggest talent like let's
say the last one in the group to jump
over all of them and come in the first
group and I was ok and I was in shock
because and I didn't want to say it too
much because maybe if I talk too much he
will change his mind I was like ok see
you on Monday then when they saw me they
saw the player that was different from
the other ones it was a great feeling
but at the same time I was like now I
have opportunity to do something good
out of it and it's pretty it's up to me
so if I want to to become something that
I think I can become I have to train
hard and that's my mentality I like to
train hard I mean you can have talent
but talent don't take you all the way so
I believe we have opportunities every
single day to cease to get better to let
people see the beam of beauty that we
are and put value out into the world and
then it's really do you capitalize on
opportunity do you say yes are you
taking that courageous step because
season the opportunity is scary because
it's pushing you outside your comfort
zone because you have to do something
that you've never done before and maybe
somebody believes in you a little bit
and you've got to believe in yourself or
do you play yourself down and say you
know what I'm not ready for that I can't
do that and the more consistently you
see those opportunities that will
reflect in the trajectory of the impact
that you have in your life I think about
trying to dance
and Alex you've seen a couple times on
the channel when he was starting his
instructor training he was working with
a female instructor who was guiding him
and teaching him how to teach it was one
of his goals to teach and in the middle
of the semester she got injured and her
back was pulled and she couldn't teach
anymore and she asked me to take over
and the challenge was I couldn't dance
with Alex right two guys are not gonna
be at the front of the class dance with
each other and so I had the opportunity
to either me jump in and lead the class
and teach and Alex could shadow and
follow along at the side and teach a
couple moves or Alex had come to the
front and teach and I would be at the
side being his mentor and I gave him the
option I said here are two options for
you I know it's in the middle of the
semester I know you're not ready forward
at all I know this is kind of crazy
last-minute I think I told him the day
of or the day before I give him both
options and to his credit he sees the
opportunity and he said I want to try I
want to do it and even though he was
afraid and even though he didn't have
all the answers and even though he made
some mistakes at the front he did it and
he got better today is one of the best
instructors that we have eternal day in
salsa and it created an opportunity that
experience of working with him created
the opportunity for him to jump from the
job that he had to become an instructor
to then being headhunted away by me to
join Toronto dance salsa full-time
because he seized that opportunity I
also believe that we have opportunities
every single day there are not as
visible hundreds of opportunities every
single day to let your star shine from
the moment you wake up to the minute
that you put your head down on the
pillow and every interaction with a
customer that you're doing with with
suppliers with partners with investors
with the media you have an opportunity
to create something for yourself that if
you just do the bare minimum you just do
the average you just do what's expected
for you that's good but if you want
something magical to happen you want
something great to happen in your life
in your career then it has to be going a
little bit above and beyond and if you
continue to in every interaction you
have with people to take that little
extra step to give them a little bit
more value than what they asked for and
what they expected then you'll see the
upward trajectory of your business and
of your career and of the impact that
you have truly take off
so for me seizing the opportunity is in
the obvious ones and the ones where it
takes some courage to say yes to an
opportunity that someone kind of
believes in you on and basing that fear
and doing it anyway as well as your day
to day hundreds of opportunities in
every action that you have in
interacting with people so the question
of the day today is I'm curious what was
the last big opportunity that you seized
for yourself that you were afraid of
doing but you said yes to anyway and you
took it on I'm curious to find out leave
in the comments below and I will join in
the discussion I also want to give a
quick shout out to Nathan law Nathan
thank you so much for buying my book I
really appreciate it makes a huge
difference to me so those of you
watching if you want your chance at a
shout out in a future video make sure to
pick up a copy of the book and then
email in your receipt so I can keep
track
thank you guys for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe or
whatever your want where it is and I'll
see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso